ce soir meurtri mystère qui met en
vedette une québécoise
surnommée la veuve noire quand ils m'ont
arrêté je comprenais rien j'savais pas
que ce qui est arrivé que ce soit
n'importe qui c'est dément sens parce
que j'ai pas fait ça mais malgré toutes
les preuves qui auraient pu l'innocenter
ça fait onze ans que judith brassard a
croupi en prison en colombie pour le
meurtre de son mari
qui sont les responsables du moteur de
philibert aura lieu comme une personne
qui est en prison qui paye pour un crime
qu'elle n'a pas commis
il ya des développements importants dans
cette saga de meurtre de mensonges de
parodie de justice deux organismes
internationaux se bat pour la faire
libérer
il y à de nouvelles sentences judiciaire
qui disent que les témoins ont menti
pour l'incriminer c'est exceptionnel
sakho sera présenté la semaine prochaine
aux nations unies c'est son dernier
espoir ici marie maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
m
québec le 26 mai 1993
c'est un longue fin de semaine au mois
de mai donc il ya un minivan qui s'est
stationné et je voyais que le chauffeur
avait comme une masse il tournait la map
de toutes les coupes et donc j'ai frappé
à la porte mais j'ai arrêté est ce que
je peux vous aider
ils sont plusieurs étudiants latino mais
judith n'ont d'yeux que pour felipe
lauras 27 ans un étudiant un pseudo
dossiers à l'université de mexico
[Musique]
judith et felipe passe l'été ensemble à
québec puis au mexique en attendant la
reprise des études de felipe on a passé
deux mois on se voyait tous les jours
c'était vraiment le père de mes enfants
l'automne venu judith est de retour au
québec
diplômé en musique à l'université laval
a accepté un poste d'enseignante dans un
collège privé de montréal mais elle rêve
d'une carrière sur scène et elle monte
son premier spectacle solo
mo
même de loin l'intense roman d'amour
avec felipe continuent elles remettent
en cause son projet de carrière
on était séparés physiquement dans ce
palais l'internet c'est peut-être pas
pour tout le monde donc que c'était
téléphone lettres puis à un moment donné
on a dit bon c'est fini ou on se marie
le mariage a lieu à la chapelle notre
dame de la victoire à québec le 6 ou
[Musique]
qui prend mari prend pays quelques
semaines plus tard judith entame une
nouvelle vie à santa marta en colombie
avec l'homme de sa vie felipe lauras
felipe c'était l'amour de ma vie il
prêtait tout le monde et al il n'y avait
pas de différences sociales qu'ils
voient comment vous pourrez être
canadienne de 10 à santa marta ya
beaucoup de différences sociales
[Musique]
les différences sociales qui ne sont pas
toujours faciles à surmonter pour une
étrangère comme judith qui vit au sein
d'une famille influente
le beau père juan roma c'est un major de
l'armée à la retraite
les familles loquace et celle de la
belle-mère il va mener qu'au son de
vieille souche en ville des familles
bien branché dans toutes les
institutions sociales politiques et
juridiques de santa marta
malgré ces différences judith s'intègre
assez rapidement elle enseigne la
musique au chic collège bilingue de
santa marta
pendant que felipe développe sa pratique
d'orthodontie ils font une famille deux
enfants mariana et felipe david la vie
de famille est intense les frères
seraient même les cousins sont
omniprésents au fil du temps le couple
prospère il achète un condo dans un chic
quartier de santa marta tout près des
beaux-parents et fréquente les meilleurs
clubs et associations de la région
c'était une personne quelqu'un y arriver
et je prenais la tension pour pour ces
jo ses farces cse était beau d'ailleurs
c'était physiquement et beau séducteur
ou pas on n'y avait pas séducteur felipe
mais volage en tout cas judith apprendra
grâce à une facture de téléphone qu'il
la trompait déjà lors de sa première
grossesse
il appelait souvent une autre femme j'ai
jamais souffert pour pour les amendes de
mon mari j'ai su qu'il y a
femme qu'il l'appelait j'ai cherché le
nom de cette équipe c'est la seule chose
que j'ai fait pour avant tout mon
mariage
le reste du temps felipe voulait
toujours chez la maison je n'ai jamais
souffert pour ça mais le climat
politique en colombie pèse plus lourd
sur le couple que les indiscrétions de
felipe
depuis cinquante ans une guerre civile
ravage la colombe pour se protéger de la
guérilla des farc les forces armées
révolutionnaires colombiennes
les familles puissantes ont formé des
groupes d'autodéfense paramilitaires qui
finissent par se livrer au banditisme et
au trafic de drogue
[Musique]
dans cette époque là il y avait beaucoup
de pêche miraculeuse en colombie de plus
pas de symptômes apparemment qu'ils
peuvent s'arrêter et qui demande
finement de l'argent ce n'est jamais
arrivé mais c'est c'était très courante
dans les années 80 18 99 2000 donc je
disais felipe pourquoi on va porter vos
canada en juin 2001 judith obtient un
poste d'enseignante à windsor
felipe doit venir la rejoindre plus tard
les enfants s'adaptent mal ça n'a pas
marché
raymond brassard et à windsor pour aider
sa fille avec les enfants felipe mais
mieux qu'à nice 6 qu'elle s'en tenait là
bas piquante analyses sont tombés là bas
ça ne le dérangeait beaucoup lui
pourquoi vous savez pourquoi
il y avait dix huit femmes amende de
mariage
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de revenir malgré qu'ils
n'étaient pas d'accord c'est là qu'on a
commencé à avoir des problèmes disons
que ya quelque chose le club au marché
c'est quelque chose qui s'est brisée
[Musique]
judith reprend sa vie à santa marta elle
retrouve son travail au collège bilingue
au cours des cinq années suivantes elle
produit des spectacles et des comédies
musicales avec ses étudiants elle
enregistre même un cd son premier
intitulé hammam et un mémoire
s'adresse-t-elle à felipe en tout cas
depuis le retour de windsor les
relations ne sont pas bonnes ce qui mène
judith à être infidèle à son tour même
si on veut garder les apparences d'une
vie familiale heureuse
le couple bat de l'air
juin 2006 judith et les enfants quittent
santa marta prétextant des vacances au
québec rendu à montréal elles entament
des procédures de divorce
son avocat lui fait comprendre qu'il
n'ya pas d'entente entre le canada et la
colombie en ce qui concerne la
séparation de biens familiaux
judith se rend donc à miami où elle vide
le compte de banques conjointe de ces
119 1000 $ en imitant la signature de
felipe
puis elle appelle sa domestique
catherine prix très un santa marta pour
qu'elle lui envoie ses bijoux à la fin
août 2006 la cour familiale du québec à
nu lui niant de judith brassard et de
felipe lauras elle accorde à judith la
garde temporaire des enfants mais felipe
contre attaque
il accuse judith d'enlèvement et
demandent le retour immédiat d enfance
le tribunal lui donne gain de cause
marianne à 11 ans et felipe david 9 ans
sont colombien ils doivent retourner
dans leur pays
on dirait quand j'ai su vraiment qu'il
fallait que je retourne mais enfin je
disais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait le jeu
juste parti c'est dans mon pays avoué
des femmes ma famille c'est juste que je
parti trop loin je parte au canada dont
6 est devenu tout est devenu plus grave
à cause de ça
le 4 décembre judith confirme par
courriel le retour des enfants en
colombie à la fin du mois puis lé dépose
à l'école et se rend au travail au
collège loyola
[Musique]
le même jour presque à la même heure
felipe rojas gnecco est abattu en pleine
rue devant sa clinique à santa marta
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
judith décide de précipiter son retour
pour la colombie
[Musique]
c'est alors que judith prend une autre
décision qu'elle ne tardera pas à
regretter
donc c'est le cas chez des souris rester
en colombie pas parce que c'était moi
qui voulait ça j'étais venu avec ma
famille dans mon pays mais je les fais
comme comme un sacrifice
donc comme pour payer que j'avais
j'avais fait quelque chose de pas
correct séparés mais en temps de la
faire puis en plus lié décédé mais son
père et mon brassard a un mauvais
pressentiment je voulais pas qu'un de
marne un bond à nouveau parce qu'elle a
entrepris les procédures de 10 dans ce
sens mais elle n'avait pas l'air de se
méfier mais vous non on en est là ce
site une bonne personne
on sent un peu de mal à une mouche très
vite après l'enterrement selon judith
son beau frère c'est raphaël lui
conseille de toucher les assurances vie
215 milles dollars de felipe elle
demande à rose et raphaël dans
l'investir 30000 pour les enfants avec
le reste elle s'achète une assurance-vie
en nommant les enfants comme
bénéficiaire
[Musique]
en décidant de rester vivre en colombie
judith est loin de se douter que ces
actions de la dernière année
l'encaissement des assurances vie
l'enlèvement de ces enfants la
récupération de ces bijoux et le retrait
de l'argent à la banque de miami et même
son infidélité
tout ça servirait d'arguments plus tard
pour la condamner
[Musique]
après l'enterrement de felipe judith
brassard décide de rester à santa marta
en colombie pour que ses enfants soient
à proximité de leurs grands parents
mais l'ambiance n'est pas très agréable
ce n'est pas une mauvaise ambiance je
n'étais pas une bonne ambiance avec
beaucoup de tristesse
c'est peut-être tout le monde tout le
monde n'en revenais pas personne savait
qu est ce qui s'était passé
[Musique]
c'est la formule de son avocat au procès
la machination avait commencé sa
belle-soeur il va martha l'accusent
qu'elle s'acharne à insinuer de façon
haineuse que judith est la responsable
du meurtre de philippe et ça c'est la
canadienne ça va c'est à cause de
l'argent qu'elle a pressé la quatrième
c'est donc c'est ça tout de suite et
elle a crié ça mais personne ne me le
disait
de longs mois passent et l' enquête sur
l'assassinât de philippe el-rass ne
progresse pas jusqu'à ce que la police
finissent par arrêter ce jeune homme
gabriel ramirez paulo l'un des tueurs
son complice qui conduisait la moto l'a
dénoncé dans une entrevue exclusive
il explique pour la première fois la
caméra comment il a tué froidement
felipe leur race ce matin de décembre
[Musique]
j'ai vu la voiture de monsieur felipe et
je me suis approché lorsqu'il
s'apprêtait à monter dans la voiture je
me suis approché davantage je les tire
est trois fois
les deux tueurs à vous ils ont été
engagés par un ancien paramilitaire
giorno sorriaux qui se trouve être le
conjoint de la domestique de judith
catherine quitter tous les quatre sont
reconnus coupables du meurtre de felipe
lauras et condamnés à de lourdes peines
de prison
reste maintenant à trouver celui ou
celle qui a commandé l'assassinât
plusieurs pistes se présentent aux
enquêteurs
dans un tout autre procès un témoin se
fait interroger sur le cas de felipe
lauras c'est un cas de vengeance dit il
l'orthodontiste aurait eu une relation
amoureuse avec la femme d'un commandant
paramilitaires crime passionnel mais le
plus troublant encore c'est la version
non corroborée de l'un des tueurs
ramires paulo juan miguel il avait une
camionnette blanche
c'est un chirurgien un médecin quelques
jours après l'assassinât en se rendant
chez john ossorio pour se faire payer
gabriel ramirez paulo voit le frère de
felipe juan miguel dans une camionnette
blanche
de là j'ai vu la camionnette devant la
maison de soleil aux hells à compaq et
et pour le frère de felipe lui a remis
un patio le solde de l'argent pour le
meurtre mais quinzaine trio
ramires paulo dit que ses complices lui
confirme que c'est bien le frère qui a
commandé et payé le meurtre je lui ai
dit pourquoi tu ne m'en a pas parlé il
m'a répondu c'est son frère qui l'a
conduit à son procès ramires paulo veut
tout révélé mais il affirme qu'on l'a
forcé à garder le silence sous menace
d'alourdir sa peine
ces témoignages chantier le véridique
on ne le saura jamais car ces pistes
n'ont pas été explorées par la fiscalité
les enquêteurs du bureau du procureur
général c'est comme s'il avait déjà
décidé que c'est judith qui avait
commandité le meurtre de son mari
ils l'ont placé sous écoute électronique
ont cherché à savoir si elle tenterait
de communiquer avec les assassins ça n'a
rien donné
l'été 2008 judith pas en vacances au
canada avec les enfants elle sait qu'à
son retour il est attendu pour une
rencontre avec les enquêteurs
elle est créative ça lui fait part ce
train quand elle sent quelque chose
elle n'avait pas le goût d'y retourner
mais elle aurait pu rester ici elle
n'aurait pu s qu'elle aurait dû rester
ici oui mais tu es seulement vacances à
son retour judith seront à la
convocation des enquêteurs
après l'avoir nié lors de l' enquête
préliminaire elle avoue avoir falsifié
la signature de son mari pour retirer
l'argent du compte de banque de 1000 m
on lui demande si elle soupçonne
quelqu'un du meurtre de son mari et elle
donne les noms qui court sur toutes les
lèvres à santa marta sa domestique
catherine pitous et son mari le para
militaires john ossorio le couple réagi
lui rende la pareille et l'accuse
formellement de leur avoir commandé et
payé le meurtre de son mari felipe
selon ossorio judith lui aurait donné
l'ordre de tuer felipe par téléphone
pendant qu'elle était à l'extérieur du
pays sur la foi de ces deux témoignages
judith brassard est arrêté le 27 août
2008 pour le meurtre de son mari felipe
rojas
quand ils m'ont arrêté je comprenais
rien j'avais pas que ce qui est arrivé
il y ont dit non il ya quelqu'un qui a
faim témoignage pour collaborer avec la
justice mais j'ai dit que ce soit
n'importe qui c'est dément sens parce
que je n'ai pas fait ça au retour le
procès de judith brassard va commencer
préparez vous au grand dérapage
[Musique]
le 27 août 2008 basé sur les témoignages
de john ossorio et de catherine pitre et
les agents de la fiscalité
les enquêteurs du bureau du procureur
général se rendent au collège bilingue
de santa marta pour arrêter judith
brassard au canada ses parents sont
catastrophés c'est étrange l'heure pour
moi
les quinze premiers jours je dormais
poche mangin porc saint-jacques
corporate braila
judith et placé en détention préventive
dans la prison de santa marta la même
prison qui renferme le tueur gabriel
ramires paulo et celui qui l'a recruté
j'en au sol dans la section des femmes
judith tombe face à face avec une autre
détenue son ancienne domestique
catherine pitre et je me suis approché
j'écoute site un quart de mer j'ai dit
la vérité dit la vérité parce que mes
enfants n'ont pas de parent puis on pas
de mal c'est pas juste
j'ai rien fait il sait puis coup de
théâtre
sa domestique catherine pitre et se
rétracte ghana au port terme à cela la
pression je ne supportais plus la
pression c'était injuste
elle a été accusée de quelque chose
qu'il n'a pas fait on a rigolé m
il ya pas moyen de pointe à la retraite
quand je me suis rendu compte des gestes
de soyaux ça m'a fait mal de la voir en
prison à cause de nous à cause de
lunettes mas del giorno soyaux qui n'a
pas accepté de nous rencontrer se
rétracte également il affirme que felipe
a été tué parce qu'il blanchit c'est de
l'argent reliés au trafic de la drogue
et qu'il devait cent mille dollars à des
chefs paramilitaires ossorio refuse de
dévoiler les noms de peur de se faire
tuer
la justice colombienne écartera c'est de
rétractation pourtant spectaculaire et
qui innocentait judith
on n'a jamais cru que rend pas c'est
parce que s'est rétracté store osorio
leur ai dit j'ai fait un faux témoignage
ll est pas coupable en rien à son mari
me dit ben coudon c'est mon sens ils
vont la faire sortir mais non
avril 2009 début du procès de judith
brassard à santa marta
la journaliste ginette la marche de
radio-canada parvient à lui arracher
quelques paroles alors qu'elle se dirige
vers la salle d'audience est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que j'allais pouvoir
dans un procès juste et c'est parce
qu'apparemment le juge s'est toujours
bien en face de tout le monde sauf que
par en dessous de chose d' influence
pour sa survie
à l'extérieur les amis de judith
manifeste mais ils sont rapidement
découragé
hector mais ça un ami de judith accuse
la famille d'intimidation
on sentait l'agression de la famille il
ne pointait du doigt comme ça et vous
m'avez demandé pourquoi le mouvement
s'est effritée passant en colombie quand
on te pointe du doigt tu te retrouves
avec la gorge tranchée
dans la salle d'audience l'atmosphère
est aussi très tendue m'attendais
d'impôts pour les familles à risque et
nokia la pré-saison mais très tendu la
famille ne voulait pas de journalistes
dans la salle d'audience avant de lots
mais eux
elle a demandé aux juges de sortir les
membres des médias pour judith est
défendu par l'avocat gustavo gonzalez
ramos lui aussi sans le poids de la
famille sur tout le processus judiciaire
[Musique]
c'est une famille puissante qui vit une
énorme tristesse une grande douleur
elle veut se venger à n'importe quel
prix
la stratégie du procureur repose sur le
premier témoignage accusatoire de john
ossorio osorio aurait proposé d'aider
judith avec ses problèmes de couple en
faisant peur à felipe ou en éliminant au
choix cette rencontre aurait eu lieu à
santa marta en juillet 2006 sauf que
judith n'était plus à santa marta au
mois de juillet
on sort jodie qui l'a acceptée
d'orchestrés l'assassinât de felipe pour
la somme de 4000 $ après avoir parlé à
judith sur son cellulaire de la
compagnie aulas alors qu'elle était à
l'extérieur du pays sauf que le
cellulaire colombien de judith était
resté santa marta osorio dit qu'il a
ordonné la mort de felipe après avoir
reçu le signal de judith lorsqu'elle
était au panama judith n'a jamais mis
les pieds au panama
ces incohérences ne semble pas déranger
les représentants de la justice
colombienne
pas plus que la démonstration par
l'avocate judith qu'il n'y a eu aucune
communication téléphonique entre ossorio
et judith preuve rejetée par le juge qui
invoque une erreur de procédure existe
et al gore dit il n'y a aucune preuve
que judith et contacté un tueur à gages
par téléphone par internet ou par
n'importe quel autre moyen
alors la grande question c'est comment
judith aurait-elle pu ordonner
l'exécution par télépathie et les
paternités lorsque le procureur a fait
sa présentation
on se serait cru au cirque avait une
allure folklorique
la représentante de la fiscalité à se
nettoyer les ongles on a même pris une
photo d'elle qui dormait pendant
l'audience
incroyable
[Musique]
pas de preuves de communication avec
john o solio pas de preuves de paiement
non plus selon lui
j'ai dit non tu loupes quand je revenais
du canada jouets de payer leur traque
redit oui alors ta crédit qui a dit
c'était tous des mensonges parce que
techniquement s'est trouvé que j y ai
pas téléphoné que j'ai pas parlé avec
lui qu il faisait n'importe quoi tout
santa marta suit le procès attentivement
la presse unanime s'en tient à la
version officielle
même avant d'être condamné judith
brassard surnommée la veuve noire est en
forme il termine un terreau propice à la
famille est intervenu auprès des
propriétaires des médias halak est sous
scellés viella on voulait que les
reportages sur le procès démontre que
judith brassard était coupable d'une
finale est l'aliment talents comme on
coule palais et à mesure
[Musique]
preuves et témoignages rejetée expulsion
des journalistes de la salle d'audience
pression de la famille sur les amis de
l'accusé et sur les propriétaires des
médias locaux un procès pour le moins
confus juste et équitable
la question se pose et le prochain show
le procès n'avait aucun fondement
rationnel l'épreuve
la justice est là où son ami tout ça de
côté
toro rosso sur le bide il s'est reposé
sur la haine
on a tourné le dos aux preuves d'aldo
les pales dallas il parle autant de
résultat une grande injustice contre
judith brassard contre 10 places
le procès dure neuf long lorsque le
verdict tombe
il est terrible elle 28 ans de prison et
2 millions de dollars en réparations à
la famille du défunt
on était convaincus qu'elle allait
sortir
on a même apporté du vin et des fleurs
sauf
c'est comme ça
judith accuse le coup difficilement mais
est ce que vous diriez vous avez été
piégé par la famille je ne sais pas est
ce que vous direz vous avez été piégé
mais piégé dans un sens si j'avais
vraiment vraiment voulu repartir au
canada je l'avais fait donc gg je veux
rester ici mais j'ai jamais pensé et il
pense ça il est trop tard pour des
regrets mais tout n'est pas perdu il
reste des recours et de l'espoir à la
cour d'appel
[Musique]
judith est en prison depuis près de six
ans dans des conditions qui ne sont pas
faciles dans un endroit où devrait avoir
5 ans donc personnellement dans ma
cellule ou dans ma chambre c'est plus
comme une chambre on est cinq pendant
qu'elle attendait le verdict du juge de
la cour de première instance elle a subi
des menaces d'extorsion cdd personne qui
aura fait jusqu'ici et l'idée le jeu je
te fais dire qu'elle se retire et envoie
20000 dollars
tu vas être libérés alors qu'est-ce que
je répondais ajouté je vous prends pas
autre tentative de corruption
après le procès le frère de la victime
rose et la file à lauras aurait tenté de
soudoyer la directrice de la prison pour
qu'elles transfèrent judith loin de
santa marta
il voulait que je lui accorde une faveur
il voulait que je la transfert dans une
prison à sécurité maximum pour qu'elle
n'ait plus de contacts avec ses enfants
je lui dis je suis une mère je fils du
même âge que celui de madame brassard
les échos migaud ne comptez pas sur moi
pas lier presse à ne pas rater pour
cause
sandra calero perd son emploi judith et
transféré près de cali à 1200 km au sud
de santa marta
elle a dû se battre et ses enfants aussi
pour revenir
[Musique]
témoignages semblables à la prison de
mende est rien
[Musique]
adriano sanchez comme à settat chef
paramilitaire bien connu il dit que rose
et raphaël horace son ancien ami et
collègue de l'école d'architecturé
aurait aussi tenté de le soudoyer
mais c'est dans la boîte il voulait que
je demande au jeune homme qui a commis
le meurtre d'accuser judith je lui ai
dit non
j'aurais pu témoigner tati mais le juge
ne voulait pas l'avocat de judith
voulait présenter mon témoignage comme
preuve des conseillers le juge a refusé
il n'y avait rien à faire et on a
condamné judith l'autre faire de felipe
juan miguel horace aurait lui aussi
offert de l'argent à l'un des tueurs
pour qu'ils inculquent judith brassard
je lui dis non je ne céderai pas il m'a
répondu si tu ne collabore pas je vais
te tuer le jour où tu sortiras de prison
je lui ai dit je t'attendrai le 20
octobre 2010 la condamnation de judith
est confirmée par la cour d'appel du
district de santa marta
[Musique]
énorme déception une fois de plus bogota
le coeur du quartier historique
la cour suprême s'apprête à réviser la
cause de judith brassard
le ministère public de la colombie c'est
à dire l'en-but ce mal de la justice
colombienne
donc l'état colombien lui-même produit
un document choc le ministère soulève
l'absence totale de preuves matérielles
ils remettent en cause la crédibilité
accordée par le tribunal aux
déclarations de john ossorio il soulève
que la preuve démontre que judith
brassard n'est pas allé au panama qu'il
était impossible qu'elle ait utilisé son
cellulaire colombien puisqu'il était
resté à santa marta et que les registres
des communications indique qu'aux rios
n'a pas reçu d'appel de judith aux dates
spécifiées dans son témoignage
pour le ministère il est clair que le
récit de john au sérieux ne correspond
pas à la réalité est qu'il faut
appliquer le principe du doute
raisonnable
il demande à la cour suprême de casser
la sentence et d'acquitter judith
brassard
judith les amis la famille sont ravis
ils sont sûrs de gagner
mais lorsque la bombe explose personne
ne veut y croire
les juges de la cour suprême confirme
les décisions des deux première instance
28 ans de prison pour meurtre et deux
millions de dollars en réparations la
famille du défunt
les juges disent que judith était la
seule personne qui a eu de sérieux
problèmes avec la victime et qu'elle
était la seule personne qui aurait pu
bénéficier de sa mort il manque un
morceau à l'histoire
à quelques pas et c'est quelque chose
qu'on veut étouffer
c'est ce écoute si la cour suprême était
capable de reconfirmer ma sentence qui
est basé sur rien de l'ère des
suppositions de ce que j'ai fait quand
je me suis séparé que de ce que j'ai
fait quand felipe et aimant comme veuve
sur aucune autre oeuvre
[Musique]
on ne saura peut-être jamais qui a
commandé la mort de felipe larrain ce
n'est qu'au avec tant de pistes
inexplorées des témoignages
contradictoires une chose reste certaine
il n'a pas été prouvé hors de tout doute
que judith brassard est responsable du
meurtre de son mari n'allait pas arrêter
de vous battre pour la faire libérer
j'imagine chez mais jamais jamais jamais
jamais tout ce qui est possible de faire
en voilà
dans un instant la finale de notre
enquête et les tout derniers
développements dans le dossier de judith
brassard
[Musique]
santa marta n'a pas beaucoup changé
depuis la diffusion de notre premier
reportage en 2014
la vieille ville est encore pleine de
charme mais elle reste surtout la prison
de judith brassard après 11 ans derrière
les barreaux
judith brassard continue à se battre
pour démontrer son innocence et
retrouver sa liberté
même si sa condamnation est aujourd'hui
chose jugée c'est à dire en principe
sans recours possible
ici la vie suit son cours et tout semble
indiquer que l'histoire de la veuve
noire canadienne est passée aux
oubliettes
en tout cas pour le grand public par
contre devant la justice le cas de
judith brassard est plus vivant que
jamais parce qu'elle n'est plus tout
seul deux organisations internationales
travaillent avec acharnement pour
trouver des preuves extraordinaires qui
permettrait de réviser la sentence est
renversé la condamnation
l'important c'est la libération de jeu
dette mais aussi de démontrer son
innocence
david berthet le directeur des numéros
un organisme canadien qui travaille dans
plusieurs pays pour démasquer les faux
témoins et faire dérailler les procès
monté de toutes pièces
on a un changement de perspective qu'on
essaie de qu'on essaie d'évaluer
parce que c'est pas fini de ce recours
là on a émis de nouveaux arguments pour
demander à la cour suprême de
reconsidérer sa décision
les autres défenseurs de judith brassard
sont en colonie et ils sont aussi
convaincus qu'elle a été la victime d'un
coup monté
quel est un bouc émissaire nous croyons
que dans ce procès il y à une fraude
et cela est une grave violation des
droits de la personne
lorena les halles une avocate
colombienne dirige les ong fondée
roussety siari verdad elle assure que
judith brassard a été victime de ce
qu'elle appelle la fabrication de
coupables oui je crois qu'elle est
innocente
il y à de nouvelles sentences judiciaire
qui disent que les témoins ont menti
pour l'incriminer ensemble ces deux
organisations ont déjà fait tomber les
deux témoignages qui ont servi à
condamner la québécoise ils ont reconnu
qu'ils avaient menti
après enquête auprès de 23 personnes le
bureau du procureur de la colombie a
accepté les arguments des deux ong et à
présenter devant deux juges différents
des accusations de faux témoignage et de
fraude de procédure à l'encontre de
catherine pitre et et de john ossorio
les unique témoin de l'accusation contre
judith brassard
ces deux faux témoins ont été reconnus
comme faux témoins condamné comme faux
témoins dans sa décision le juge
considère que la version de john ossorio
étaient contradictoires et inconsistante
et que les déclarations contre judith
brassard n'était pas crédible
mais le magistrat va encore plus loin en
assurant que la justice n'aurait jamais
dû condamner la canadienne à cause de
l'existence d'un doute raisonnable
finalement avant de condamner les faux
témoins le juge soutient que leurs
déclarations ont entraîné la
condamnation d'une personne innocente
effectivement c'est faux témoignages ont
incriminé une innocente qui paient pour
quelque chose qu'elle n'a pas fait les
deux faux témoins ont reconnu les faits
et ils ont été condamnés de la
commission john ossorio qui a donné au
moins sept versions différentes des
faits et qui est aussi l'organisateur du
meurtre a écopé d'une sentence de 10 ans
4il pitt et sa femme a été condamné à
six ans de prison après 2,1 c'était un
miracle que ces deux personnes là disent
la vérité
c'était vraiment un miracle que qu'ils
acceptent leurs fautes qu'ils acceptent
de dire on a fait un faux témoignage
c'est pas vrai elle avait rien à voir la
simple
enfin une bonne nouvelle pour judith
brassard nous l'avons rencontré il ya
quelques semaines juste après ses 100
ans la québécoise a aujourd'hui la
possibilité de sortir temporairement de
sa cellule une permission que je peux
sortir trois jours par mois 120 gigas
mais il faut que j'attends je suis
toujours dans la nature c'est certain je
veux pas être fermé judith brassard est
convaincu que c'est grâce aux enquêteurs
et aux avocats des organisations
canadiennes et colombienne des droits de
la personne que sa vérité commence à
émerger
finalement aujourd'hui mon innocence a
été prouvée mais les tribunaux colombien
ne sont pas encore rendus là il a
canadienne est consciente du fait que sa
libération définitive n'est pas pour
demain
légalement je me rends là 3 le 3 5e de
ma peine j'aurai droit la liberté
conditionnelle à partir du mois de
décembre cette année mais avec la
révision j'aimerais beaucoup que ce soit
avant soit un autre élément vient
réconforter la québécoise et ses espoirs
de voir la justice réviser sa
condamnation
presque au même moment que les sentences
contre les faux témoins sont prononcés
un scandale de corruption frappe de
plein fouet la justice colombienne la
commission leonidas bustos ancien juge
en chef de la cour suprême de justice
est accusé d'avoir organisé et dirigé un
cartel judiciaire le cartel des toges
qui vendraient des sentences de la cour
suprême au plus offrant ce qui est
incroyable c'est qu'il s'agit du juge
qui a confirmé la sentence contre judith
brassard
difficile de savoir si le cas de la
canadienne a fait partie de ces
tractations douteuses
ironie de la vie selon les médias et des
politiciens colombien l'ex magistrat
leonidas busto serait au canada où il
voudrait demander l'asile politique
il se cacherait ici pour éviter son
procès nous ne sommes pas encore
parvenus à le retrouver
supprimant des postes issia confirmant
de la sint nsia délà de la senyera
judith brassard
les défenseurs de judith brassard crois
que la justice n'a pas fait son travail
à l'époque où elle a été condamnée alors
ils ont mené leur propre enquête
selon leurs conclusions les vrais
coupables du meurtre de felipe horace
n'ont jamais été inquiété par la justice
il insiste il faut rouvrir l'enquêté
pour trouver les vrais coupables
il ya toujours une personne qui n'a pas
été l'objet d'une enquête
c'est la personne qui aurait
véritablement commandité l'assassinât
donc la personne qui aurait commandité
l'assassinât de philippe est une
personne qui était un informateur de la
police de
de santa marta cet informateur de la
police appelle victor son nom a été
mentionné pendant l' enquête mais il n'a
jamais été accusé par les procureurs
et ce n'est pas le seul cas la justice
est au courant d'un témoignage affirmant
qu'un arc aux trafiquants extradé aux
états unis auraient avoué dans une
prison américaine
être derrière l'assassinât du mari de la
québécoise mais cette piste non plus n'a
pas été explorées la question est
évidente pourquoi je dis tu sers comme
comme personnage elle c'est comme bouc
émissaire elle sert tant qu'elle est
coupable tant qu'elle est en prison
cela fait en sorte que l' enquête
l'investigation pour pour savoir qui est
ou qui sont les responsables du meurtre
de fait les biographes bailly il reste
en liberté il reste protégé
juste avant la diffusion de notre
reportage coup de théâtre la famille de
felipe lauras le mari de judith brassard
qui a été assassiné a demandé
l'annulation des sentences contre les
faux témoins ils veulent empêcher la
révision du procès et ils s'en prennent
aux juges
dans un avis juridique l'avocat de la
famille assure qu'il n'ya jamais eu de
faux témoignages et que ses 100 ans sont
le résultat de la mauvaise foi de
l'ignorance ou de la naïveté des juges
mais il ne reste pas là il affirme que
ces jugements n'ont qu'un seul objectif
rouvrir le procès de judith brassard
et enfin que la sentence nuit aux
intérêts de la famille de la victime
parce qu'elle affirme que judith
brassard n'aurait pas dû être condamné
et la cour suprême leur a donné raison
judith doit rester en prison selon elle
il n'y a pas d'éléments suffisants pour
annuler la sentence de judith brassard
ni pour ouvrir lé enquête sur
l'assassinât de son mari
[Musique]
ces actions de la famille devant la
justice n'aide pas à trouver la vérité
ni à élucider ce qui s'est vraiment
passé
au contraire ça vient mettre des bâtons
dans les roues pour causer un préjudice
à judith qui reste en prison autrement
dit pour la cour suprême colombienne
il n'y avait que la canadienne qui
pouvaient profiter de la mort de son
mari
et cela fait d'elle la responsable la
plus plausible
devant cet acharnement contre judith
brassard en dépit des démonstrations de
doute raisonnable et de présomption
d'innocence ses défenseurs ont décidé de
jouer le tout pour le tout la semaine
prochaine son cas sera présenté devant
le groupe de détention arbitraire du
conseil des droits de l'homme des
nations unies
il espère qu'une décision favorable des
nations unies aura un poids décisif pour
forcer la justice colombienne a révisé
le cas de la canadienne de comme une
personne qui est en prison qui paye pour
un crime qu'elle n'a pas commis qui
était séparé de sa famille de ses
enfants de ses parents qui sont hissés
judith brassard devra donc encore être
patiente
son dernier espoir repose entre les
mains de la communauté internationale en
attendant après chaque permis de sortie
elle doit se résoudre
encore et encore a frappé à cette porte
de prison où elle ne voudrait jamais
retourné
[Musique]
on va évidemment suivre et vous tenir
informés des développements dans le
dossier de judith brassard c'est tout
pour ce soir au nom de toute l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là revenez
nous la semaine prochaine pour une autre
enquête
[Musique]